[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is National Master Ralph tan and
welcome to beginner's breakdown today
we're going to take a dive into the
concept of decoys so to illustrate let's
take a look at this position from
1983 versus varsity and pogar so what is
a decoy a decoy is a tactic that lurs a
piece away from its square and its job
so let's evaluate this position quickly
so black has 1 2 3 4 Five Pawns black
has 1 two 3 4 five six Pawn so white is
up a pawn both sides have their Rooks
both sides have minor pieces and both
sides respectively have their Queens so
what we can notice in this position is
that pogar would love to take this Rook
on
B4 but
unfortunately white has this Rook on
A2 that can capture The Rook on A8 and
if we do a count here the material is
equivalent but we don't really gain any
significant advantage in this position
so what we want to try to do here is
kind of lure the piece away that's
protecting this Rook that's on A2 so
when we capture on B4 if we were to try
to take this Rook the queen would be
protecting it so what pogar did in this
position was to move Bishop all the way
to C4 and now Bishop to C4 is a fork so
it attacks two or more pieces at the
same time it attacks the queen and it
attacks The Rook so if the queen moves
away then we can safely capture the rook
and if the Rook moves away then we can
capture the
queen so Queen takes C3 looks like a
free Bishop but here and now we can play
Pawn takes B4 and as we take this Pawn
on B4 it is now attacking this queen on
C3 so if black tries to capture our Rook
on A8 we can capture the queen and we
will be up a queen for a knight here so
if white tried to let's say play Queen
C2 to protect the Rook on A2 we can
simply just trade off Rooks and after
the queen takes we are up the exchange
so Queen for Queen Bishop for Bishop and
we have a rook for a knight in this
position so we up the material here so
let's take a look at some examples here
all right
1978 we have Edgar versus frommlet so so
white to move and create a decoy in
order to gain an advantage here so let's
evaluate this position white has one two
three four pawns black also has one two
three and four pawns both sides have
their Rooks and both sides have their
Knights so what we can notice here is
that this Knight on G3 is kind of
putting a little pressure onto this Pawn
on F5 but unfortunately for white this
black king is defending F5 so we can't
really capture on F5 otherwise the king
would take back here so we need to find
a move that kind of lur the king away so
we can safely capture this Pawn on
F5 so we typically want to look for some
active moves they include checks
captures or threats so the ideal move in
this position would be bringing our Rook
all the way to D6 so attacking the King
on E6 so this Rook on D6 is completely
undefended so it looks like black can
actually capture this Rook on D6
completely for free but that serves our
whole idea of playing Rook to D6 which
is to kind of lure a king away from
protecting this Pawn on F5 so there is
no Pawn there the king is no longer
protecting this Pawn on F5 so what white
can do is safely capture on F5 with a
check so now this move is a tactic it
creates a fork so it attacks the king
and it attacks The Rook at the same time
so once the king let's say moves away to
E6 we can happily just capture Out The
Rook on H6 and if we do a count white
has 1 2 3 4 black has 1 two three and
both sides have their Knights so white
is up a pawn so the whole idea of this
combination was to win a pawn which
would s which will pretty much satisfy
us in this end game here and in addition
to Rook to D6 check there are a couple
options black could play they could also
play a move like King E7 which probably
isn't the best idea because we can just
capture on F5 and not only does it
attack the King on E7 it protects Rook
on D6 and it attacks The Rook on H6 so
once black moves out the way from the
check we can happily capture The Rook on
H6 here and last but not least let's say
if the King goes to F7 we can pick up
the pawn on F5 and we should have a
pretty clean end game being up a
pawn all right how about we take a look
at the next one so
1975 we have we have Pari versus edly so
white to move and create a decoy here
find a decoy so it's always good to
evaluate the position first so let's do
a material count for both sides so why
has 1 2 3 four five six pawns black has
1 2 3 four five six seven pawns so seven
is bigger than six so black is up a Pawn
here and we have both sides have a rook
both sides have a queen and in addition
here looks like black is at a more
advantage in material because they have
a rook for the bishop so they are up the
exchange
here so what we could also notice here
in this position is that there's a bit
of tension from the C1 diagonal all the
way to the F4 diagonal so both the
Queens are are eyeing each other down so
if white is careless and let's say plays
a move like Bishop to F3 then black
could capture this queen on F4
completely for free and let's say if
black makes a move and we can capture
their Queen on C1 they can easily just
recapture back on
C1 so that's kind of the big idea in
this position so we know notice that
there's some tension between the Queens
the queen on F4 is unprotected and the
Queen on C1 is protected
here so ASA in the chat says Rook check
so I'm assuming that would be Rook to G8
check and I think that move is perfect
so with this move Rook to G8 check black
has two options here they could either
capture it with the Rook or they can
capture it with the the king let's just
take a look what happens if the Rook
captures if the Rook captures The Rook
on G8 then the queen on F4 will capture
the queen on C1 because the Rook is no
longer on C8 so it's no longer
protecting the queen so white has gotten
away with capturing a queen for a rook
so white has a queen and Bishop for two
Rook so plenty of material
there so would Rook to G8 What happens
if the king captures on G8 fortunately
for us we have a very strong active move
here so we kind of lured the king out of
its Comfort its little home in the
corner on h8 so what we can do here is
play this move Queen to G3 check so the
only safe check for us in this position
can't play Queen to G4 because the
Pawn's covering and we can't play Queen
to G5 because the queen on C1 is
covering that square so Queen to G3
check is to move and now black has two
choices technically three but if you
block with the queen we'll simply take
so two main choices here either black
goes home with King to h8 back to the
corner or the black king can go to f8 if
the King goes to h8 we can play Queen to
G7 Checkmate as the pawn on F6 is
protect
this queen on G7 and the queen covers
all the squares that the king can go to
and attack the king if the King goes to
f8 then we can still play Queen to G7
but it's not yet mate because the black
king can go to EA and then we can now do
Checkmate either would Queen to GA
Checkmate or queen to h8 Checkmate both
moves get the job done
Perfect all right how about this example
here so
1969 we have bruad versus Bray Mir white
to move and find a decoy so we want to
find moves that essentially kind of lure
one of our opponent's pieces in and then
we could take advantage of that so let's
evaluate this position let's do a
material count so white has 1 2 3 four
pawns black has 1 2 two three four five
pawns so it looks like black is up a
pawn here both sides have their queen
and a rook respectively and the
imbalance here is that white has a
bishop for a knight so they're equal but
different pieces here so now what we
want to try to do is find a way to in
order uh find a way to distract one of
Black's pieces in order to gain an
advantage here so a big thing I'd also
like to notice here is that the
placements of the Kings so our King on
H2 it's pretty safe we have a fortress
with a bishops and pawns and in addition
it has some safe squares to run away to
unlike the black king on H6 it is
completely trapped by its own pieces and
our Rook is covering H7 and
G7 here so in the chat we have Abraham
who says Queen takes H5 check oh we're
sacrificing Our Queen so Queen takes H5
check that forces black to capture Our
Queen black has no other legal move and
then and now we can finally play this
move Rook to H7 and this would be
Checkmate so it attacks the king C H7
and our Pawn on H3 and G3 are doing a
wonderful job covering G4 and H4 and the
pawn and Knight are covering black
squares so that is check me so
originally we couldn't play a move like
Rook to H7 beforehand because black
would simply capture and this move order
would let black have a significant
Advantage so hence why we captured on H5
first distra in the king from guarding
this H7 Square so once the king takes
then we can now provide checkmate with
Rook to
H7 all right we're on a roll let's take
a look at the next position so
1974 we have Brit Norris versus Goodman
white to move here so it's always good
to do a material count so white has one
two three four pawns black has one two
three four five pawns so black is up a
pawn both sides respectively have their
Rooks a queen and they have the
imbalance of the Knight for the bishop
here all right so what we can notice
here in this position is that there's a
lot of stuff going on on the E file
here so we have our Rooks both our Rooks
on the E file so we call that a battery
so a battery is two or more pieces
controlling a file rank or diagonal
together and in this case both the Rooks
are on the same file and just creating a
strong control over this e file so maybe
we can keep that in our mind and in
addition we should also take a look at
Black's King it is very vulnerable it
has absolutely no squares to go to so
the bishop covers f8 Our Queen on F6
covers G7 and it covers h8 so no squares
for the king to go
to so in the chat we have tww suggesting
Queen to h8 check so we're giving our
Queen away and that forces black to
capture Our Queen so then and now we can
play this move Bishop to F6 with a check
here attacking the king and as you can
notice everything is forced so black has
to go back to the square that it came
from so King to G8 and then and now we
can deliver Checkmate by bringing our
Rook all the way from E2 to E8 covering
the f8 square attacking the King on G8
and covering h8 alongside with the
bishop covering the G7 Square so that is
checkmates all right next position we
have a position from
1991 hyberg versus pocket
gansi so white to move and create a
decoy so we're getting the pattern of
distracting luring Black's pieces or our
opponent's pieces into squares where we
can take advantage of that in this
position so as always let's take a quick
material count so white has 1 2 3 4 4
five six pawns black has 1 2 3 4 five
six pawns as well so both sides are
equivalent Pawn wise and both sides have
two Rooks and both sides have their
Bishop here and last but not least both
sides do have their Queens here so a
good thing to take into account here is
that black uh is attacking Our Queen on
D before so that kind of gives us a
little bit of a hint that maybe we want
to try to you utilize Our Queen in order
to gain an advantage
here so a lot of us in the chat are
saying Queen takes bishop and I couldn't
agree anymore Queen takes Bishop on D7
attacking the king so black has two
options here they could either capture
to quit Queen on D7 or they could simply
slide their King to f8 which is probably
the best choice for black but in this
case let's just say black does capture
on D7 so now since this king is on D7 it
is actually lined up with our Rook on
D1 but we just have this bishop on D3
blocking our way so so now our job here
is to find a move where we could place
this bishop so we can uncover this Rook
from attacking the king and this tactic
would be called a discovery so what's a
good Square for our
Bishop so we have the move Bishop to B5
double check not only does The Rook
attack the king also the bishop on B5 so
whenever a King is in double check they
have to move their King they can't block
it or and they can't capture the check
here so with Bishop to B5 check here it
covers the E8 Square so the king cannot
go there and it looks like Black's only
move is to play King to C8 as our Bishop
on E5 is covering the E2 Square uh C7
Square excuse me and The Rook is just
dominating the dile and now here we can
deliver the final blow so notice that
our Rook on the dile is covering d8 and
D7 Alward Bishop on E5 is covering C7
and B8 so all we need to do is find a
move that attacks the King on C8 and its
safe Square B7 so what could that move
possibly
be and the correct solution would be
Bishop to A6 finishing off the game
attacking the King on C8 Bishop once
again covers C7 and B8 and our Rook
dominating the defile excellent all
right let's take a look at the next one
position from 1990 hner versus bezer so
BL to move and create a decoy so getting
the pattern of distracting our opponent
pieces and then fully taking advantage
of them so let's evaluate this position
black has 1 2 3 4 Five Pawns black had
uh excuse me white has one two three
four five pawns as well so both sides
are equivalent Pawn wise both sides have
a queen a rook both sides have a light
Square bishop and the imbalance here is
that black has a dark Square Bishop for
a knight
so we should also take into account kind
of the king safety of both sides so both
so our King on F7 is a little bit
exposed it has some squares that go to
and preferably we would like to have it
sheltered by pieces so maybe the king
would probably prefer to be on h8
covered by the rook and Bishop but our
King is pretty open and now for white
they're kind of enclosed they're kind of
safe but they only really have one safe
Square to go to which is G2 cuz Albert
Queen on C5 is covering the G1 Square so
maybe we could try to take
advantage of White's King here as a lot
of White's pieces are kind of in the
center or on the queen side here so what
would our decoy be what would our little
distraction be here
so a lot of us in the chat says Queen to
G1 with a check so we're giving black uh
excuse me white a whole Queen so with
Queen to G1 check that
forces white to captured a queen and now
we can deliver kind of the same idea
that we did from last uh uh puzzle
here so what would that
be
so Bishop to D4 here would be our move
here and the idea being is that the Rook
is attacking the king and in addition
the bishop is attacking the king so it
is a double check so once again whenever
a king is in double check they have to
move away they can't block the check
they can't capture the check because
there's two pieces attacking the king so
now once the king runs away to the
corner to H1 then we can deliver the
final blow of checkmate with the Rook to
G1 Checkmate as the bishop on D4
supports the Rook into attacking the
king and covering the G2
Square all right sounds good let's go on
to the next one so white to move in this
position from
1991 tin versus Meszaros here so it's
always good to do a material count white
has 1 2 three four five pawns black has
1 two three four pawns so white is up a
pawn both sides have their Queens both
sides have their Rooks and both sides
have a knight light Square bishop and
dark Square Bishop here so we can prob
probably notice a big thing in this
position and this King our opponent's
king the black king is all the way from
A6 so it went from E8 all the way to e
to A6 somehow so looks like we want to
utilize that advantage of just pushing
the king all the way to the queen
side so what could we possibly do here
so the King has no SC safe squares to go
to so A5 B6 is covered by our Knight and
B7 and B5 are covered by our Bishop and
we would love to kind of bring the final
Hammer to black but we kind of do have
some pieces in the way they're not fully
coordinated so what could we possibly do
in this
position so in the chat we have the
suggestion of Bishop to
B7 check wow okay so with Bishop to B7
check that forces black
to play the only move which is to
capture the bishop on B7 and once a
black captures on B7 we can deliver the
final blow of Queen to A4 so this bishop
on C6 was in the way of this bishop of
this queen from going to A4 so what we
need to do was kind of move the bishop
aside so kind
of uh remove it from allowing the queen
from going to A4 and it kind of
distracts black it kind of forces black
to capture uh be s with the queen and
this queen now moves so we don't really
have to worry about protecting the B7
Square because it's covered by a queen
so Queen to
A4 would be Checkmate as it attacks the
king covers the B5 square and our Knight
on B6 does uh Knight on C4 does a
wonderful job protecting the B6 Square
very nice all right how about this
position so so we have a position from
1990 between Luther versus mayor so
white to move and create a decoy so
create some sort of distraction in order
to gain a full advantage here so let's
take a quick evaluation here so white
has one two three four five pawns black
has one two three four five six pawns so
black is up a pawn and both sides have a
queen
and a
rock so what could we possibly do here
in this position
Rook h8 Che okay so we have the move
Rook to h8 check very nice so with Rook
to h8 check that forces the king to
capture on h8 but when when that King
moves away it stops protecting in this
H6
Pawn excellent so the queen will just
capture on H6 and after the King goes to
G7 we can play Queen to G7 Checkmate
protected and supported by the pawn on
F6 now that is a good solution but there
is a faster solution so we always want
to find the fastest way to get to our
destination we would rather
take a quicker route than a long
route okay very nice so it looks like we
just had to swap over move order so
Queen to H6 this time instead of Rook to
h8 so after Queen takes H6 that forces
black to take and then we can slide a
rook all the way to h8 Bam Checkmate
Pawn cover Pawn on H4 covers the G5
Square our Pawn on F6 covers the G7
square and our Rook covers H7 and H5 and
also attacking the king so this actually
took two moves with Queen takes on
H6 and Rook to h8 and the other move
order took three moves so either one
works but it's all it's always good to
be more productive and efficient by
going for the
quicker uh execution
here so let's take a look
at a couple more and then we'll go on to
a game so in this position from
1943 we have thelon versus
chodera and it is white to move here so
it's always good to do a quick
evaluation we have 1 2 3 4 5 six pawns
for white and black has 1 2 3 four five
six seven pawns so black is up a pawn
both sides have a queen both sides have
their Rooks and both sides have a knight
and a bishop
here so we can notice
that white is following more of the
middle game principles as this Rook on
D1 is controlling the defile and Rooks
love open files so any time you can get
your Rook to an open file do it and
white is doing an excellent job doing
that so full control maybe they can
place pieces on the D file as it would
be supported by the rook and in addition
white has a piece in the center so
looking really good here so now it is
our our job as white to find a decoy
here so kind of distract black kind of
lure him into a trap and then try to
take full advantage of
that
so Knight F6 check Knight to F6 check oh
that's pretty tricky Knight to F6 check
and you're saying if you try to take my
knight off F6 take my Bishop you're
going to take my Bishop oh boy well sure
that looks good and let's say I play
something like Rook a to B8 if we kind
of do a quick little material count as
previously the imbalance here is that
there's a bishop for a knight Queen for
Queen both sides have their Rooks and
black has seven pawns while white has
six pawns so there's still added
Advantage here so when whenever we have
tactics we want to fully utilize them
and kind of flourish the idea of gaining
a full advantage here so in the chat we
have a very tactical move Rook
to ah Rook to D7 yes so with Rook to D7
it looks like we're just a very nice
person today we're just giving material
but this Rook on D7 is poison so there's
a little trap when this Rook is captured
so with this Rook on D7 it attacks the
bishop and the Queen at the same time so
we have a fork so if one of them moves
then we'll capture the other so for
example let's say the bishop goes to C6
we're going to capture the queen and
we're going to be up a lot of material
here but now the big question arises
what happens if black captures
Albert
Rook F6 excellent so yes our Knight can
now hop into the F6 Square because
previously we can't really play Knight
F6 because the queen was guarding that
square but as we play Rook to D7 we kind
of lure the queen away so now we can
freely play Knight F6 and now with
Knight F6 it attacks the queen and the
king at the same time so we have a fork
so once black moves away we're going to
capture the queen and we are looking
very very good in this position
here
so does black have any other options
besides capturing The Rook because if
you capture The Rook we notice that
there is a fork
so how about Queen to E8 I kind of step
away from your Rook being a from your
Rook attacking my queen I take the
Knight
on not F7 that's a long way but Knight
to F6 yes bam we are still going to play
Knight F6 we scared the queen away so
the whole idea was just stopping the
queen from guarding this F6 Square so as
the queen goes to E8 we play Knight to
F6 check King goes to h8 and then bam
we're taking the queen and unfortunately
here there are no safe squares for black
for the black queen Rook covers the d8
square Queen uh Knight covers uh F6 and
G5 and our Pawn on G3 covers
H4 Perfect all right last puzzle here
for decoy we're going to end this puzzle
off with a blast we have a position from
1958 we have Porsche versus dorier and
it is white to move
here so it's always good to evaluate the
position so white has one two three four
five six pawns black has one two 3 four
five six seven pawns so black is up a
pawn both sides respectively have their
Queen their Rooks and both the bishop
pair so black is just up by a mere Pawn
but that is a okay CU what white can do
here set up a little trick and
essentially just end the game right
there
mhm so if we try to captured a bishop
here
unfortunately our Queen on G4 is
unprotected here so the black queen can
just capture on G4 and we traded a queen
for a bishop not the best idea here so
how about we go for an aggressive move
let's go all
in we want to try to bring black a
little bit forward and then we want to
punish them
here so a lot of us in the chat I truly
couldn't agree anymore and what we want
to do is bring our Queen and tell the
black king on G8 hello so Queen takes G7
face to face with the black king so that
forces the black king to capture the
queen on
G7 and now we've probably seen this
pattern a few times in our puzzle today
what could we do
here to H4 I H5 we could play Rook to H5
here because it does kind of attack the
king and it attacks the queen but what
black can play is maybe like Queen F6
and even if you do this black is up a
whole piece so both sides have their
Rooks both sides have a light Square
bishop and black is left over with a
dark Square Bishop but we can finish
this game off right off the bat is it
Rook cross Bishop no Rook takes Bishop
if we do that maybe they can just go
here all right do we see itook G5
excellent Bingo Rook to G5 and it looks
like it's a double check but it's
actually Checkmate so we can just say
say this is double Checkmate so our Rook
on G5 attacks the King on G7 and in
addition this bishop on C3 attacks the
King on G7 our Bishop on D3 covers the
H7 square and our Bishop on C3 covers h8
with this Rook covering G8 so that is
Checkmate
excellent so I think we are getting a
good gist of the concepts of decoys so
how about we take a blast in the past
and take a look at a game where decoys
were involved here so we're going to H
we're going to go to the Toof Memorial
in
1977 so this game in particular is going
to be against carolly huny versus llio
barazi so a little bit about these
players carolly huny was a Hungarian
chess player and he holds the title of
of international Master but later on
post humously he was awarded the
honorary grandmas title and he is
playing white in this game and Lazio
barazi is black in this game and he's a
Hungarian chess Grandmaster and he has
one of the greatest fats in the 1966
chess Olympiad with a score of 11 out of
12 which allowed him to win win the gold
medal so let's take a dive into this
position here into this game so huny
opens the game up with E4 and Bazi opens
the game up with C5 so we have a
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 we have D6
D4 so striking into Center captures
Knight captures Knight F6 Knight C3
everything's pretty much practical we
have A6 so the idea being that flat does
not want any infiltration of White's
pieces coming to B5 and in addition who
knows maybe black might support B5
themselves so we have Pawn to F4 so kind
of the kind of following the Spear of
the grand Pricks attack or L Fish so
just immediately pushing pawns on the
king side trying to be really aggressive
when it comes to the cicilian in the
center so we have Queen to B6 so early
development in the queen so just kind of
keeping an eye on this Knight and if
white sometime in the future tries to
Castle there will be this pin here so
white plays Knight to
B3 and black plays G6 so getting ready
to Fen Shadow and get their King to
safety here so Bishop E2 so standard
development we're looking good knight B
to D7 and Bishop to F3 so we're
developing and essentially maneuvering
our Bishop
to uh be at a better Square than it was
beforehand so black plays to move Bishop
to G7 so fan shadowing the bishop
getting ready to Castle here white plays
Queen to E2 so moving the queen out the
way maybe white wants to try to Castle
Queen side
and there might be ideas to kind of
fully expand on the queen on the center
so castling is played by black here and
then we have G4 so white is really
aggressive in this game so since white
has noticed black has castled on the
king side they're trying to create a
pawn storm so essentially bringing all
these pawns to attack where the king is
located in order to win the game as
quickly as possible
so black plays to move E6 so essentially
trying to stop ideas like Pawn to F5
coming or trying to support D5 typical
uh Sicilian ideas here so with white
plays Bishop to E3 so we are developing
and in addition we're gaining a Tempo
because this bishop is attacking the
queen on B6 so Queen has to move so
Queen C7 is played
and G5 white is just really aggressive
attacking black the Black Knight on
F6 all right black Retreats with Knight
to
E8 and in addition it also activates
this bishop so this bishop is looking
really good in this position so with
that in mind white wants to combat this
and plays Bishop to D4 trying to offer a
trade of the Bishops the less favorable
Bishop for for the more favorable Bishop
so black plays E5 does not want to trade
today maybe later and attacks the bishop
and also attacks the pawn on F4 here so
white happily takes and black decides to
take with the Knight so the idea being
wants to try to get this bishop active
and able to see here and able to move so
that's probably why black did that
instead of capturing with the pawn
here and actually if capturing with the
pawn there might be some ideas with
Knight to D5 something scary so Knight
E5 is Knight takes E5 and Knight to D5
is still played Queen to d8 so kind of
have to move the queen away and also
guard the E7 Square so got to be a
little careful here and then Pawn to H
H4 so white is still gone for the idea
of being real really aggressive and just
committing to this Pawn storm trying to
attack the king so black wants to finish
development and just plays Bishop to E6
and with Bishop to E6 it contributes
towards the center and it also attacks
this Knight on
D5 so white finally gets the king to
safety and castles long side here and
black notices that the Knight on D5 is
really really strong it can maybe come
to B6 maybe bishop to B6 might be a
little bit of a nuisance so black might
as well chip it
off so white captures back and Knight to
C7 is played by black so the n on E8
wasn't really doing too much so it's
best to try to bring the Knight back
into life so now this Knight can maybe
have ideas of maneuvering to B5 and kind
of also putting a little pressure onto
this D5 Pawn so Bishop to E4 is played
so kind of wants to avoid the Knight on
E5 capturing the bishop and we're fully
centralizing this bishop so now this
bishop has a little bit more visibility
when it comes to the king side so Queen
E7 is played so kind of adding more
protection lining up with the queen and
who knows maybe they might even play
Rook to E8 and support the E file so
King B1 is played always a good
precaution move to play Whenever you
Castle Queen side so Knight to B5 is
played so bringing the Knight back into
life and now attacking this bishop on
D4 Bishop to F2 is played so we want to
preserve our Bishop kind of have it in
our pocket it could be very useful in
the future and Rook F2 E8 is played by
black so they're battering up on the
dile and just getting ready to be very
solid in this game here so Rook D to E1
is played by white so also creating a
battery and there's a lot of tension
going on with the e file here so
F5 played by black so very aggressive
and just wants to create some sort of
action in this position so white could
most definitely move their Bishop away
to G2 but that kind of gives black a lot
of space and might even give black the
full advantage here so the best thing to
do is on pisan so we're kind of capture
the F5 Pawn through the F6 square and
now the queen will take back so now this
is a good thing to keep in mind so the
black queen and the black Bishop are
creating a battery so two or more pieces
controlling a file diagonal or rank
together and in this case with the
bishop and queen they're controlling the
diagonal from h8 all the way to do A1
here so they have full capitalization on
this diagonal and who knows there might
even be tricks where black can kind of
somewhat give up their Knight in order
to go for this sneaky little checkmate
with Queen takes
B2 so C3 is played so White's reading
black like a book they see that Queen
takes B2 it's going to be a pro a little
bit of a problem here here so play C3 in
order to kind of intervene from black
trying to Checkmate white on
B2 so now we have a little bit of a
decoy here but when it comes to decoy we
want to try to gain full advantage when
we use tactics so Knight to C4 was
played and essentially the idea
is I want to distract your queen and I'm
going to take your Bishop on F2 because
this queen on E2 is protecting this
bishop on F2 so that happened in the
game so Queen takes C4 and queen takes
F2 so now the queen is on the seventh
rank again is being a bit of a nuisance
so we're going to scare him away we're
going to play Rook to E2 scaring the
queen away and the queen goes back to
its Square on F6
so uh give
redoing the battery so Queen to D3 is
played in this position so kind of
creating a battery themselves and also
in case if the there's some sort of
attack like let's say Rook
A8 it kind of prepares for that so a
little bit of a prophylactic move by
Queen to D3 and Rook a to C8 is played
so trying to find some sort of ideas
where it can fully break white so let's
say if white is careless maybe plays a
move like H5 there might be some scary
ideas with Knight takes C3 Pawn takes
Rook takes and there could be some
mating Nets or there could
be other things around maybe Knight A3
check is first but in the game here
white plays this move Pawn to C4
and essentially what white is trying to
say is that I'm trying to fully uh gain
space attack this Knight on B5 and I'm
not worried about my B2 Pawn at all
there is no Checkmate because this Rook
on E2 is protecting the pawn on B2 but
unfortunately here that proves to be it
shows that C4 is a fatal mistake here so
now what could black try to do so we
kind of want to influence this
combination so we're going to find a
catalyst here so black to move and kind
of take advantage of this mistake that
white has played pushing it advancing
this Pawn
here so what could we try to do as
black so this Pawn on C4 is protected by
the
queen so maybe we could ignore that idea
so in the chat we have some ideas with
Knight to A3 check now Knight to A3
check not too shabby but unfortunately
here I believe white could just simply
capture this Knight and and I think
White's pretty solid there is no mating
threat set here so there's no Queen to
B2 because of this rook and there's no
Queen to A1 because of this Knight here
so Knight
A3 not the best idea but we can maybe
preserve that in our pocket
here
okay so it looks like we have the
suggestion of Rook takes E4
interesting now I'm kind of curious what
the idea is here so after Rook takes E4
Queen takes E4 and Rook takes C4 H so
we're being very generous as block today
so we're giving both our Rooks so after
that after Queen takes I think white is
just at a huge Advantage with plenty of
material and if there is any combination
I think white has enough to compensate
for that so it's a good try but maybe
we're kind of
overdoing okay so the C4 Pawn it's kind
of bugging my mind a little bit here
sure it's protected by the queen on D3
but I believe we can follow that up with
a combination
here so I want to kind of distract the
queen and kind of place it where I can
gain where I can perform a combination
here so we have Knight to D4 suggested
by chat and with Knight to D4 I would
say that's pretty good but it doesn't
really give us a decoy or any sort of
Advantage if anything I think it's more
of simplification here because let's say
Knight takes Queen takes Queen takes
Bishop takes I'll play a move like Pawn
to B3 I'll have this nice little Pawn
chain here and opposite color Bishop so
white has the advantage here but it
doesn't really gain an immediate
Advantage but I do like the thinking of
centralizing theight and getting away
from
the
threat so we
have sacking The Rook okay so we looked
at Rook takes E4 which doesn't really
work but how about the other Rook let's
try Rook takes
C4 okay so would Rook takes C4 it kind
of lurs this queen on D3 to capture this
Rook on C4 because there's absolutely no
pieces is guarding this Rook on C4 so
looks like white can simply capture The
Rook but now here we have this nice
little forcing move here so if we can
notice here the king and the
queen are a knight distance or somewhat
of a knight distance away so if we were
to place this Knight on A3 we would have
a fork
but we can't really play Knight to A3
right now because they'll just simply
capture our Knight and they are just at
a huge material advantage here so that's
why Queen takes B2 check is our move
here and now with Queen takes B2 it
looks like that's just a blunder because
the whole idea of this Rook being on E2
was to protect this Pawn so white could
simply just capture on B2 but
fortunately for us not only did we
create a decoy we also removed a
Defender so this B2 Pawn was protecting
the A3 square but the Pawn's no longer
there so now we can play Knight to A3
check so this is what happened in the
game so Bazi plays Rook takes C4 huni
takes on C4 and Bazi plays Queen takes
B2 so after Rook takes Knight to A3
check is played so a fork attacking the
king and the Queen at the same time and
that kind of forces white to have only
two options here so either King to C1 or
King to A1 so in the game King to C1 was
played if King to
A1 it is a little bit worse because
after black takes on C4 there is a pin
here so very devastating attack Knight
also attacks the B The Rook on B2 so
let's say if white tries to preserve
this bishop let's say D3 since it was
being attacked by The Rook on E8 black
could probably just take and let's just
say we move the bishop
again black is just a little bit better
because they are up a pawn or they are
up two pawns actually so white has one
two three and black has one two three
four five pawns so should be a clean end
game here so that's why barazi chose
King to C1 here in this position
and we could most definitely take our
Queen take the queen but if we do
White's going to play this move Rook to
E2 and if we do a little quick count of
the
material white has two Rooks a bishop a
bishop and a knight while black only has
a rook and a knight and Bishop so we are
actually down a whole Rook so what we're
going to need to do first is make an
intermediate move so an in between move
so make a move that creates a threat
before we make our obvious move which
would be wanting to take the queen so in
this position black captures The Rook on
B2 attacking the king and once the king
deals with the check so capturing the
bishop black can now capture the queen
delivering a check to the King on B2 and
in the game King to C3 was played so
King is now attacking the Knight on C4
and if we try to protect it black can
play Bishop to D3 and they'll be up a
whole piece so that's why Rook takes E4
is played in the game so looks like
material minor pieces and major pieces
why is is pretty equivalent Knight for
Knight Rook for Rook but the
pawn uh pawn count is just devastating
so white has one two three black has one
two three four five so a lot of pawns
for black so the game ended very soon
Knight to D4 was played so trying to
create some sort of interference
blocking The Rook from protecting the
Knight so Knight to D4 but after Knight
to B6 white threw in the towel because
after Knight to B6 it attacks this D5
Pawn which can hardly be saved so even
if white tries to play something like
King to D3 there's a move like Rook to
E5 and then next move the pawn is long
gone so
uh black wins this game barazi wins this
game and that showed that decoys can be
a really effective tactic in order to
gain full compensation and Advantage as
we saw in this game and the previous
puzzles earlier so thank you guys so
much for attending beginners breakdown
and understanding the concepts of decoys
with me and I hope you have a wonderful
[Music]
evening